i was the first woman
president of an african nation
and i do believe
more countries ought to try that
once the glass ceiling has been broken
it can never be put back together
however one would try to do that
when i assumed the presidency of liberia
in january 2006
we face the tremendous challenges
of a post-conflict nation
collapsed economy
destroyed infrastructure
dysfunctional institutions
enormous debt bloated
silver service we also faced
the challenges of those left
behind the primary
victims of all civil wars
women and children
on my first day in office
i was excited
and i was exhausted
it had been a very long
climb to where i was
women had been
those who suffered most in our silver
conflict
and women had been the ones
to resolve it
our history records many women of
strength and action
a president of the united nations
general assembly
a renowned circuit court judge a
president
of the university of liberia
i knew
that i had to form a
very strong team
with the capacity to address
the challenges of our nation
and i wanted to put women
in all top positions
but i knew that was not
possible and so i
settled for putting them
in strategic positions
i recruited a very able economist
from the world bank to be our minister
of finance
to lead our debt relief effort
another to be the minister of foreign
affairs
to reactivate our bilateral
and multilateral relationships
the first woman chief of police
to address the fears
of our women who had suffered so much
during the civil war another
to be the minister of gender
to be able to ensure the protection
and the participation of women
over time the minister of justice
the minister of public works minister of
agriculture
minister of commerce and industry
participation and leadership
was unprecedented in my administration
and although i knew that there were not
enough women with the experience
to form an all-women cabinet
as i wanted i settled to appoint
numerous women in junior ministerial
positions
as executives as administrators
in local government
in diplomatic service in the judiciary
in public institutions
it worked
at the end of 2012
our economic growth had peaked
at nine percent
our infrastructure were being
reconstructed
at a very fast pace
our institutions were functioning
again our debt
of 4.9 billion
had been largely cancelled
we had good relationships with the
international monetary
fund the world bank the african
development bank
we also had good
working relationships with all our
sister african countries
and many nations all over the world
are women who sleep peacefully
at night again without fear
our children were smiling again
as i promised them during my first
inaugural address
the reputation and credibility
of our nation lost in the many years of
conflict
were restored
but progress is never guaranteed
and in our legislature in my first term
women were 14 in the second term
it declined to eight percent
because the environment
was increasingly toxic
i had my fair share of criticism
and toxicity nobody is perfect
but there's nothing more predictable
than a strong woman
who wants to
change things who's brave to speak out
who's bold in action
but i'm okay with the criticism
i know why i made the decisions i made
and i'm happy
with the results but that's why
more women leaders
are needed but there will always be
those who will tears down
who it tears apart because they want the
status quo
to remain
although sub-saharan africa
has had major breakthroughs
in women leadership
and participation
particularly in the legislature
in parliament as it's called
so many women 50 and over one of our
nation
well over sixty percent the best in the
world
but we know that's not enough
why we must be very
thankful and applaud the progress we
have made
we know that there is much more work to
be done
the work will have to address the
lingering vestiges
of structural
something against women
in too many places
political parties
are based on patronage
patriarchy misogyny
that tried to keep women
from their rightful places
that shut them out from
taking leadership positions
too often women
face while the best performers
while equal or better incompetence
unequal pay and so we must continue
to work to change things
we must be able to change the
stereotyping
we must be able
to ensure that those structural
barriers that have kept women
from being able to have the equity
they rightfully deserve and we must also
work with men
because increasingly
there is recognition that
full gender equity
will ensure a stronger economy
a more developed nation
a more peaceful nation
and that is why we must continue to work
and that is why with partners
i will be launching a center
for women and development
that will bring together
[Applause]
[Music]
women who have started
and are committed to their joining
of leadership with women
who have excelled
and advanced in leadership
together over a
10-year period
strongly believe
that we will create this wave
of women who are prepared
to take unabashedly
intentional leader
and influence throughout the society
this is why
at 81 i cannot retire
women are working for
change in africa
women are working for
change throughout the world
i will be with them
and one of them forever
thank you for listening
go out and change the world